The Joe Rogan experience,
you're here,
man,
here,
here when you were talking about Alaska,
you know,
and getting off the grid and all that.
Uh,
you know,
I had a transformative experience that first time I went to Alaska,
I was in college in New York,
I was studying literature and one of my teachers was a visiting professor that I
got to be friends with.
Was the youngest person to ever be a professor at Oxford.
He's like a real big shot at Oxford.
I mean,
since 12 slash 61 or something.
This guy's the youngest person to ever be a professor.
Then how old was he?
Twenty one when he was a full focus on.
Yeah.
Anyway,
he's very well known guy.
Indira Gandhi was his godmother.
He's written a bunch of books and all this and he was a friend of mine and he
was uh,
I was in my,
I was,
skipped my junior year of college and the,
so I had a one more year of undergraduate and then I was going to go to Oxford
for my phd,
thanks to this guy and his connections and I was going to study literature
there,
do a phd and by the time I was 30 be teaching somewhere hopefully have tenure
and be all set for life.
And so I skipped my junior year because I found a loophole in the student
handbook where I could like scan through,
which I've done like every school I've ever been in,
every job I've ever had I find some scam.
Right.
So I,
I a scam my way out of junior year and I said I'm going to go to Alaska because
I want to see the frontier.
So I hitchhiked from New York to Alaska.
Had all these freaky adventures as you can imagine.
Right.
Went to prison,
got shot at all this crazy shit happen.
And I met people along the way who picked me up,
especially like in the Yukon and in Alaska who were so fucking kind.
Yeah.
So competent and they take me home.
I,
you know,
they feed me,
introduced me the wife,
the kids that,
you know,
or women who'd stopped and picked me up.
Just trusting like,
Hey,
whatever,
you know,
really self sufficient people.
They built their own houses,
they had healthy relationships.
They knew how to fix their own cars.
They were really self sufficient.
None of them knew anything about the fancy schmancy literature and philosophy
that I was studying.
Right?
Like I,
I had,
you know,
the collected poems of Dh Lawrence and my backpack and they'd never heard any of
this shit.
Right.
But when I compared them to my professor friends back at school and I was like,
wait a minute,
these people don't know any of this,
you know,
the elites knowledge.
But they're really happy people and they're healthy people and they have good
families and they're decent and they're kind and they're generous to me.
And then I imagine one of them,
you know,
stumbles into Princeton,
New Jersey,
or you're aware I was going to school in upstate New York and my professor
friends,
you know,
come upon them,
they'd,
they'd laugh at them,
they wouldn't help them,
they wouldn't be kind to them.
They went and my professor friends like had to call the fucking electrician to
change a light bulb.
Right?
So it's like,
well,
why wait a minute,
what do,
what do I want to do in this life?
Where am I going?
So that's when I just said,
all right,
fuck it,
no Grad school.
And I wrote the guy like,
just,
sorry,
not going to print,
stir a Oxford.
Not,
not going to do any of this till I'm 30,
I'm not going to make a commitment to anything.
No job,
no woman,
no Grad School,
no med school,
nothing.
I'm just going to float around the world and have adventure.
Wow,
that's fucking cool story.
I love that idea.
That's a,
that's really cool.
I found that,
uh,
I didn't go to the Yukon but I went to anchorage recently with already.
Right.
And you guys went fishing?
We went fishing.
You the Kenai peninsula
south of Anchorage.
I'm quite honestly,
I don't remember.
I don't remember what river on remember.
Yeah,
we had a great time.
Yeah.
Uh,
we caught some salmon and we did a show up there,
but I,
I felt that way as well about the people that self sufficiency to a lot of the
folks that live up there that eat meat.
Even in Anchorage,
which is a city,
you know,
it's a real city.
They have hotels and gas stations and the whole deal.
Movie Theater went to the movies there.
It was 10:00 at night.
It was bright out.
Yes.
Very weird bars with no windows.
Yeah.
You can't get every windows because people were in there drinking.
You don't want to say the fucking sun coming here.
I let you know what a loser you are actually A.
Yeah.
And people will make better decisions if there was a light on them.
We don't want that.
So do they still have a handgun permits where you have to leave your gun at the
door when you go into the bar?
Someplaces gun check?
Yeah,
you have to check your guns and you come in because everybody's got guns.
Get Shit faced.
Then you pick up your gun on your way out.
Yeah,
that's the best time to get it.
After you've got an apar architects that you find people there,
they were very kind and very cool and very competent as you were saying,
and they're just.
There are people that are also dealing with nature in a way different level
they're dealing with whether it's real,
whether.
Yeah,
and we don't have to do that.
We,
especially in California,
which is the most ridiculous and retarded state in the country as far as the way
people behave on the norm,
and don't get me wrong,
I love it here and there's a lot of cool people here and you know,
all my best friends are here,
but the reality of California is that we don't have to deal with weather at all.
The worst thing we have to do is press a button.
Oh my God,
it's hot.
You press a button.
It's not hot anymore.
I mean,
it's really.
As long as the power stays on really not that fucking hard to deal,
but if you're living in Alaska,
you have to take precautions every year.
You have to keep a candle in the back of your car.
You have to keep matches.
You have to keep blankets with you at all times because your car could break
down.
You could be at the side of the road,
no one could be on the road and that candle,
it might keep you alive.
You have the light that candle in your car with all the doors shut and that's
the only way you're going to stay warm,
stay alive.
Like there's A.
There's a lot of that kind of thinking going on there.
And then when someone sees you pulled over to the side of the road,
they're not like,
oh,
who's this creepy fuck,
you know,
in Sherman oaks that pulled over to the side of the road with his hazards on,
I'm not stopping to this guy,
right?
They're like,
Oh,
who is this person,
this kindred soul out here in the middle of the woods that got fucked and this
could be me.
Come on in.
Do you guys have cell phone service?
No.
If we drive five more miles,
we get cell phone service.
Hop in the car.
I'll take you where we can call somebody.
Yeah,
there's not that,
but you're right.
Your professor friends,
to not pick them up would be right where they live.
That's the crazy thing about it.
It's like you're right that the professor was probably wouldn't pick up someone
who has broken down the side of the road,
but they're right too and not doing that.
If you live in a city because you never know what the fuck you're going to get.
Exactly.
Yeah.
You got it.
You got to participate in the world you're born into whether you agree with it
or not.
How's that smell?
Is that okay?
I don't even smell it.
Yeah,
let's go in that way.
Damn.
What's wrong with you?
Because someone,
you know,
son,
you should smell the fuck out of that.
It's nice.
I don't lie to me,
man.
I'll put it right out.
Hardly noticed that.
I tell you.
I mean,
I know it must be the coke.
How dare you.
Okay.
That's a bad drug.
That's a drug I had access.
I mean I,
you're,
you're in this position all the time,
I'm sure,
but you know,
having access to the best of the best of something.
I knew a guy in college who was the son of an oil minister from a country I
won't name,
just to keep me out of trouble.
He had a private jet.
He used to fly to Columbia.
He had a diplomatic bag so he could bring anything into the country.
He'd bring the shit into the country and he was like in this frat and I knew
someone who was in the Frat and I was never a frat boy at all,
but they would invite me and like these,
like yellow rocks of cocaine.
And it was the.
I mean I went to this dumb ass college where everybody was rich.
So the drug scene there was off the charts and I've done the best coke there is,
right?
I mean I know the guy who invented Mtma I got,
I had these really good connections for drugs and coke sucks the best in the
world.
Don't get it.
Wow.
I mean,
my,
in my sense is that it,
it affects a certain personality structure in a really pleasant way and I don't
have that structure.
So for me,
hallucinogens are like boom,
that's pushing my button,
right?
Coke,
it just made me fucking nervous and drink too much.
You're a self deprecating guy and you joke around about a lot and you also
introspective and I think that one of the things that people don't like about
people that are cooked up is that they want to talk about themselves.
They want to tell you how fucking bad ass they are.
They want to brag,
they want,
they want to talk about like making money.
We're going to buy this forest,
we're going to fucking,
you know what I mean?
Like Mike Young used to always talk about how uh,
people on Coke always want to start a business with you.
And it's really kind of true.
It's like they always have these.
Yeah,
they have these crazy grand plans and it just,
I,
I've never been interested in it.
I got lucky and I ducked it when I was a kid.
I've told the story a hundred times,
but I had a friend,
my friend that I'm still friends with in high school,
his cousin used to sell it in his life,
went down the toilet and I watched him wither away,
lost a shitload of weight and became weird,
you know,
just always on coke and when they weren't,
wasn't on coke,
he was just exhausted,
you know,
it's just like Jesus that looks like a,
like no one.
Someone who got bit by a vampire like,
oh my God,
like you got you get that bug.
They got you.
Yeah.
It's like you're taking all the energy from of your life and concentrating it in
the few hours after you do the coke and like,
well,
what are you going to do with all that energy?
Except irritate
people.
But I knew a girl and she was a great girl.
She wasn't a mean person.
She wasn't nasty,
materialistic.
She's beautiful.
She's really nice and sweet and kind.
But fuck.
She loved coke.
God Damn.
And she would feel bad about it.
She'd got fucking love it.
I love doing coke and they're like,
really?
Like what?
I,
you know,
I was not curious enough to want to do it,
but listening to her,
you know,
she knew it was bad news.
She shouldn't do it,
didn't want to do it anymore,
but she'd tell you,
God damn what I'm doing,
I love doing coke.
In my experience,
the people who tend to get really hooked on coke are people who have,
um,
issues with,
uh,
they feel bad about themselves.
They feel they've got a lack of self esteem.
They,
they feel like they,
they're not good enough.
They're not whatever.
There's shame and all that because the coke takes that away for awhile.
That totally makes sense in this case because this woman,
her mother was like really overbearing and her mother was like Super Alpha
successful.
Her mother was a single mom and was like,
like,
no man is going to fucking run me and show she was a lawyer and she ran
successful business.
She had a law firm and she was like super,
like intense with her daughter about achievement,
about pursuing things,
about,
you know,
don't eat the wrong foods.
And you know,
he just,
it was like really like,
overbearing and gave her a hard time about her weight.
Like,
you're too fat,
you're never going to be a model.
And like,
Uhm,
and so I guess the coke was like,
Oh,
free.
You don't have to think about it.
Give her.
Maybe she had a deficit created by her mom's constant,
just never letting her just be herself.
Yeah.
You ever,
you know,
Gaba is.
No,
he's.
Yeah,
I,
it didn't know the name.
I've only seen it written.
He's,
he's a cool guy.
And if you ever want to have him on the show,
let me know.
He's,
he's a friend of mine.
He's a very interesting guy.
He's a doctor who works with addicts and he's been working with addicts in
Vancouver in the slum part of Vancouver for a long time.
A lot of like real down and out people.
Um,
and he also is very interested in alternative approaches to addiction.
And he's written about Iowasca as a way of dealing with addiction,
treating addicts and all that.
But anyway,
he,
uh,
his theory is that all addiction is due to trauma.
It's not,
it has nothing to do with the substance or the activity,
it's,
that's just how it manifests,
right?
But it's all about psychological trauma.
It's all trying to alleviate suffering of some point of some kind.
And um,
it,
it's interesting,
his research a sort of meshes well with this experiment that was done also in
British Columbia.
I can't remember.
Marie Williamson,
I think was the scientist's name,
you know,
those famous studies where they give rats like a,
they've got a water bottle,
it's just water and then another one that's got coke in it and the rats will
just keep doing the coke and they'll forget to eat and then they like die.
Like these people you're talking about lost all this weight and just like
completely focused.
This guy looked at that.
He,
he was a professor scientist.
He looked at it and he's like,
okay,
well that,
that's the sort of main study that everybody cites that shows that coke is
addictive and it's coke the causes of the problem and it's the substance and
molecular problems.
But what if we took those rats a same kind of rats,
but instead of just being in a cage where there's nothing to do,
put them in a really interesting environment where there are lots of other
options,
there are lots of other rats they're tubes to go through and things to climb and
things to hide under and lots of stimulation.
Right?
And then let's try it.
They try it.
What happens?
The rats through the coke once or twice and then walk away from it.
Never go back.
Right.
So there's an argument to be made that a strong argument that it's not about
substances.
It's like I was saying,
it's about the way this substance,
inner sex with whatever your particular suffering is,
right?
So these rats in a cage are obviously suffering because they're not in a natural
environment or in a fucking cage.
There's nothing to do except like get high.
So they get high.
That's a very good point that I never considered.
That is a very,
very good point.
It's called rat park.
If anyone wants to google it,
just google rat park.
[inaudible].
That's what he called this.
You know,
like sort of enclosure that he made for the rat and a rat being stuck in a
fucking fluorescent lighting room and fucking metal cage and the little water
bottle you gotta suck on big to the fucking life they live is dog shit.
You're in a prison.
So you got,
you got to prison,
a guy in solitary confinement,
right?
And you're offering them to get high.
Of course it's going to get high and you're being surrounded by giants
everywhere you go.
This is enormous creatures who can easily reach in and just snuff your life out
of squeezing.
It's ridiculous.
And by nature you're terrified,
right?
Because you're a prey animal.
You're,
you know.
Yeah.
You shouldn't be running from everything and all of a sudden you can't run.
You can't hide.
Right.
And they just reach in and grab you and they fucking give you a coke.
Yeah.
Which makes even more pair.
Shitty life.
God Damn Pita might have a point.
Yeah.
I remember.
You know,
when the dusk,
when the mosquitoes come out and you can see a swarm,
you're setting up your tent,
you know,
and like I remember setting up my tent and like every second moving my shirt so
they couldn't like get in through the shirt,
you know,
I had to keep moving the shirt while I'm setting up the tent and then you get in
there and you can hear it.
It's like hail banging against the side of the tenant.
You can hear them banging on the tent.
Oh my God.
Yeah,
they're,
they're little helicopters.
The fuck did people do before they figured out tense?
Uh,
well the Eskimos,
I believe they smeared fat on their skin that would,
certain kinds of fat would keep the mosquitoes off of them and they've got all
sorts of really clever adaptations,
you know,
we,
we sort of assume that we would be helpless,
but that's because we didn't grow up there and our culture didn't,
you know.
So there's,
you know,
Wade Davis is a,
he's a,
he's an anthropologist,
he's written a bunch of books,
really interesting guy.
He's,
um,
like anthropologists in residence at the Smithsonian in Washington.
He wrote a book called the wayfarers I think was his last book about
traditional,
like,
about how these guys could navigate across the Pacific,
just looking at the stars and the color of the water and smelling and whatever
they'd.
Anyway,
he,
uh,
one of the stories he tells us about this,
Eskimo guy,
old guy and the family sort of took the keys to the car away from him.
Like you can't go anymore.
They were afraid he would go out and die the traditional way when Eskimo people
got old,
they would just like wander off into the ice and die.
So as not to be a burden to the family.
Right.
And he was a traditional guy and they were worried that he would take the,
the snow machine out and just die out there somewhere or hurt himself hunting or
whatever.
So they had this whole intervention.
And so that night he goes out,
gets out of the house,
takes a shit in his hand,
forms the shit into a knife,
blade,
spits on it,
and the spit a is freezing along the edge and he hones that down.
So he gets a nice sharp edge with his sped,
takes his shit knife,
kills a dog or a couple of dogs and takes their ribs and makes us a sled out of
it.
And with the sinews and whatever other pieces of the dogs,
you know,
he knew all this stuff from his childhood,
hooks up a couple of other dogs to the sled and he takes off into the,
into the snow,
on his sled with his shit knife.
Oh my God.
That might be the most insane story I've ever heard.
And they're so clever.
You know how they killed polar bears.
I know they take blood and put it on a blade.
I know that method that was actually wolves.
The wolves would lick the blade and uh,
we would,
uh,
they would cut themselves to death,
similar kind of thing.
What they would do is they take a little,
they'd make a wooden box and they would take a seal,
a rib and sharpen the two ends of the seal rib and they're pretty flexible.
They bend it and stick it into the box,
right?
And then they'd pour melted fat into the box and let it solidify freeze and then
knock it out.
So you've got a fat cube with this flexed to bladed thing inside it and they
leave that in the snow.
Polar bear come along,
swallow it,
and opens in the polar bear and they just follow the blood drops and it would
kill them.
Yeah.
Internal hemorrhaging.
What would it take to kill him?
I don't know.
I just remember that.
I mean,
there are stories like that all over the world.
You know,
the Indian monkey trap,
the East Indian monkey.
I don't know how interested your readers or your listeners.
Well,
that system is,
and this is a good metaphor to.
I always remember this one.
They would take,
um,
same thing,
take a box with a hole about a little smaller than a fist in the mail.
In the box,
and then they put a mango in the box and then hammer it shot and tight to a
tree.
So the mango starts rotting,
the monkey smells it.
Monkey comes along,
can stick his hand in and feel the mango,
but he can't get his hand out as long as he's holding onto the mango and they
won't let go of the mango.
All they have to do is let go and they could leave,
but they've got the mango in their hands and they won't let go.
And so the guy comes around to check the traps.
There's the monkey standing there with his hand in the box.
Hit It on the head.
You've got your monkey.
Whoa.
Sort of something about greed there.
That's an awesome story.
That is a perfect metaphor to him.
Yeah.
That's amazing.
Wow.
Let go of the mango.
That's my advice.
That's funny.
All Right Gentlemen,
I think we're,
uh,
we're at three hours,
three hours.
These things fucking fly.
They fly by.
They'd been amongst the most popular podcast that I do.
And I know you guys are saying the same thing.
Well,
he's pretty good at the one we did together last time.
I guess mine was the third,
right.
Um,
has twice as many downloads as any other that have been up forever.
And the second is you,
you and me
the same thing with us.
I mean these,
these podcasts that we have are amongst the highest downloaded ones that we
have,
you know,
just take effect.
The one we did for sure is the most direct downloads.
They're really fun,
you know,
fun.
They're bizarre.
It's very bizarre.
A combination.
I don't know if you guys saw,
I created a page that archives them.
Okay,
cool.
I'm happy to transfer it wherever we decided to do it,
but for the moment it's on Chris Ryan,
Ph d dot Com.
And you'll see tripod cast tab and that's where the first three are archive.
It's just a link that leads back to your site and your site.
We were talking before the podcast started about trying to figure out a name,
but we're not even close old men in the snow.
That was pretty bad ass because of your description of what it is.
Right?
But with people,
it's funny,
without knowing the story.
No,
you have to tell the story though,
just tell people to start because I don't think he did while the podcast was
going on.
It was before the POC.
We were talking about,
uh,
techniques that,
that adolescent boys develop the good ones anyway for not coming.
And uh,
and like some people like think of baseball stats or whatever.
Just something like nonsexual to get your head away from what you're doing,
which in itself is kind of a weird thing to be,
you know,
you're having the best experience of life and you're trying not to notice.
Nature wants you to come instantly and just shoot a load into a chicken,
make a kid,
and you want to have a good time,
a strategy,
very zen.
Well,
it goes back to sex at dawn.
It's,
you know,
a sperm competition.
Yes.
Nature has designed you to shoot your load,
get out of the way.
So the next guy can.
Exactly.
And that's why by the way,
were turned on by seeing gang bangs and dude's fucking a b.
You are.
Yeah.
Anyway,
so my technique was to think about old people trudging through the snow,
like World War II,
you know,
Crimean refugees,
trudging through the Russian winter freeze.
Any of that.
Yeah,
I like that about Bush.
exactly.
That makes me not want to come and go with that guys.
Sorry guys.
I can't come now.
Yeah,
that guy's asshole.
Imagine,
would you live the rest of your life if that guy's an asshole was permanently an
inch from your face?
Oh,
it isn't guy.
Yeah.
What would you do for the rest of your life?
Well,
you can live.
You can do everything you want and go
fucking
asshole block.
You're always be like no right here to the right.
You can move it around,
but it always has to stay like sorta like the moon is in your orbit.
That guy's an asshole.
His raw.
You know what?
After a week or two,
you wouldn't even notice it and say that I would kill myself.
I would kill myself.
Push that guy with me.
I would just.
I didn't show him my life.
Fart in your face.
Perfect.
Everlands in the wrong place.
That's what the Buddhists say.
Hot Air conditioner.
Yeah.
Okay.
Both you guys.
It'll ruin it.
Yeah.
I can't go to prison for saying this.
Right.
You're talking about this.
This is a serious thing,
but you know what non-americans,
if you admit that you have ever used illegal drugs,
they can stamp your passport.
You're never allowed in the country.
I have two friends that happened to.
So if you're in another country and you start talking about using drugs,
like on another podcast,
they can.
I don't know about podcasts,
but what happened with his friends,
she was coming back from Amsterdam.
She was a judge in the cannabis cup competition and she lives in Vancouver and
the plane,
she changed planes in Seattle and they took her and said,
so where are you doing in Amsterdam?
And she told them and they said,
so have you smoked marijuana?
She said,
yeah,
and they stamped her password.
She has never landed in the US again because she smoked marijuana in Amsterdam.
Wow.
Guy knows a psychiatrist,
a Canadian psychiatrist who had worked with LSD psychotherapy and they stopped
him at the drive through border.
You know,
at Vancouver and interviewed them,
they wikipedia'd him and they're like,
oh,
you did a research with LSD.
Have you ever used Lsd?
And he said,
yeah,
stamp.
Wow.
He's never allowed in the country.
That's crazy.
That's all.
Is that only America as far as I know,
Canada's rough.
If you get them drunk driving in America,
good luck in Canada.
Oh really?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
A lot of,
um,
a lot of fighters have issues getting into Canada for fights.
A lot of comedians have issues.
A lot of comedians have had issues getting into the Montreal comedy festival,
which was one of the big events for standup comedian because of drunk driving.
Yes.
Because a drunk driving or any domestic violence or anything like that.
Eddie Bravo had an arrest for having a gun on him legally.
Okay.
He was working for a check cashing place and he used to have to carry large sums
of cash in his car to another location and so he would leave with the check
cashing company and he had a registered concealed carry permit for a gun.
And so he got pulled over for something and he had to tell the,
uh,
the cop officer,
I worked for check cashing company.
I have a legal registered handgun in my car right now.
It's loaded.
And then they go,
okay,
hold on a second,
we're going to put you in handcuffs.
I'm going to run this.
So they,
they run it,
they go,
okay.
Checks out.
They let them go because it was not even supposed to be on his record because it
was all legal.
Doesn't matter.
Every time he goes to Canada,
they sit him down.
That was about this.
You have a gone on side.
You right now you take a gun,
you should go for the border.
No,
no,
no.
I was,
I was working for a company I was allowed to have like it.
Cut.
He's got an extra hour every time he goes into Canada.
That happened to me quickly in immigration going into Canada.
What'd you get a,
what was your issue?
Well,
they asked me if I'd ever been convicted of a crime and I said no.
And I go sit down and then they call me over and they said,
uh,
the guys like,
um,
you said you'd never been convicted of a crime,
correct?
I said,
yeah.
He said,
is there anything you'd like to say about Fairbanks Alaska in 1983?
I was like,
uh,
yeah,
I got busted in Fairbank's,
you know,
uh,
for eating a snickers bar and the fucking grocery store and not paying for it.
And,
but I did three days.
It was Memorial Day weekend.
I did three,
four nights in the prison,
and then the guy said,
you know,
20 hours of community service and this will disappear from your record.
And again,
if you don't get arrested in a year.
So I always say no because that's,
yeah,
I wasn't convicted of anything and they said it would be taken from my record.
And the guy's like,
nope.
The fact that you were not Alaskan so you're from out of state meant they
couldn't strike it from your record and it's on your FBI record,
which is what we get in Canada.
So he was knicker thief.
Yeah.
I'm a sneaker thief,
so he's a cool guy.
I did four days in effect in a federal medium security prison with no underwear
for a snickers for sneakers.
What do you mean with no underwear?
Were you wearing anything or just naked?
I was wearing why have pants at the grocery store?
Because it makes it more harrowing.
Come on man.
I was.
I was 19 years old.
That.
Yeah.
Will you liked very twink?
Ish.
I was twinkie.
I was very twinkie.
So you were worried it was all going to go down.
I would have been worried if I were wearing,
you know what anything
is that even.
Isn't that under the amount of money that they could even bust you for
something?
Maybe not in the eighties.
Reagan was president.
They were trying to fucking be tough on crime.
Just say no.
Yeah,
and also I had a,
I mean what happened was we got in from this 10 day hitch with these two,
I'd met on the ferry coming up the inside passage and we had this long hitch
through the Yukon territory,
all this crazy shit in the.
And we get to fairbanks,
so the first place we go to the laundromat,
because we stank,
right?
We didn't have that special soap,
your defense defense.
So,
and uh,
so we went to the laundry mat.
We put everything possible in the Washer,
so all three of us were wearing shorts with no underwear,
boots with no socks and a jacket with no shirt.
And then one of the guys was like,
oh,
he wanted to go to the grocery store because there was a pe fund.
He was going to call his girlfriend to let her know that he'd arrived on time.
And I was like,
Hey,
I'll go over with you and the other guy's going to stay with the bags or
backpacks and all that shit.
And you know,
watch the clothes.
So I went with him.
Somebody who's on the phone,
we start pushing a cart around.
We were like Soviet immigrants,
like,
oh,
so many kinds of food here because we'd been living in the woods eating nuts and
chocolate and lsd for the last 10 days.
And so he,
he opened a,
a thing of Keifer.
First time I'd ever heard of Keifer,
which is like liquid yogurt.
Yeah.
And drank that great for your body Acidophilus and I uh,
I for some reason eight,
a snickers bar even though I'd been eating chocolate,
not much.
Imagination there.
And then we,
he used the phone,
we ditched the cart and we left and so there's some security guy had seen us and
turned into a thing.
This cop showed up and I had a knife in my boot and some grass in my pocket,
both of which were illegal at the time in Alaska,
but it was enough to make this cup not like me at all.
And he was like this,
you know,
he napoleonic cop kind of situation and he didn't like smart ass college kids
from outside coming into Alaska in the summer.
And you want a snickers bar fucking around fucking around with Kiefer.
So he took us,
he handcuffed us and took us to prison.
Fairbank's correctional center.
Did you not have the money for the snickers bar?
Yeah,
we had plenty of money.
He just didn't want to pay for it,
but it was like,
well,
you tell it to the magistrate.
Oh,
you mean for that.
Now that was just like,
I don't know what the fuck you're just young and we're just filling.
Um,
and,
you know,
and maybe there was a line or something I don't remember,
but we pretended we were shopping so we put like dog food and Shit in the cart,
you know,
and we ate our stuff and put the,
the package,
like we were going to pay for it when we checked out.
Right,
right,
right.
So I don't know what we were just being dumb.
But uh,
yeah.
So we ended up being taken to this prison and I had a pipe to.
Yeah,
because I remember when we were,
did the intake,
the guy that liked the prison dude who booked us and you know,
do the whole intake thing.
I was joking with him,
I was like,
yeah,
I'm not going to get that pipe and grasp back,
am I?
And he was like,
I don't think so man.
I was like,
well know it wouldn't bother me if it just disappeared and was never even
registered because grass is hard to come by.
And Alaska wasn't then and so we sort of had a little understanding like,
I'm cool,
you're cool.
Because he was like,
what the fuck?
You have snickers bar,
why would this guy,
what's wrong with that cop?
Did you like hit him or something?
You like?
No,
you know,
he just had a hair up his ass.
Right?
So this guy was cool.
He saved us because what he did is he said,
look,
I'm not going to put you guys in with the general population.
You're going to sleep in the gym at night.
I've got some cots.
You Sleep in the gym,
you never let the other one out of your sight the whole time you're here,
you go to the bathroom together,
you go to the showers together,
you watch each other's back and you'll get through it.
All right?
And we did anyway,
it was wild and this was like 83 I guess.
And um,
so the,
there's a lot of money in Alaska,
right from all the oil.
So the prison was plush.
It was like every meal was all you can eat,
salad bar,
whole wheat rolls,
white rolls.
Wednesday was prime rib day where the cops could pay a buck to eat with the
prisoners.
But the catch was you only have 20 minutes each meal.
So I'm married like one day we're sitting there at this table and we're in like
19,
maybe 20,
something like that where we're sitting at this table and the guy across the
table looked like Charles Bronson,
you remember him,
the stash and the tats and all that.
And we're just like this dude who is shoveling it in and he looks up at one
point he says,
this is the best fucking prison I've ever been in
a
yikes.
You've got a laundry list of prisons that don't,
don't meet that criteria.
Standard.
Yeah,
he,
his story was he founded dude with his wife and he beat him with a lead pipe and
he didn't know if he was dead,
but as soon as it happened,
he got in his car.
He was from New Mexico or Arizona.
He got in his car and drove to Alaska because he knew he'd get picked up and he
wanted to get picked up in Alaska because he'd heard the prisons were much
better.
That's hilarious.
So he might've been the guy to death and said,
the way to deal with this is to go to a place that has awesome prisons in that
place.
Just happens to be on the exact opposite of the barns and a fucking forest shit.